we need heroes we need you  Captain Marvel is about somebody who  goes on a journey of discovery and I  think it was really important for breed  to learn how to fight by the time we  started shooting I had been training for  nine months and I'm glad that I did  doing fight sequences up him down or  training for three days  well gonna live the thing that I found  so unique about this character was that  sense of humor mixed with total  capability and whatever challenge comes  her way you know how to fly this thing  you see which I realized after going to  Air Force Base is really what Air Force  pilots are like that's a yes or no  question yes  we simulated a dogfight we were on  offense we were on the defense we got to  6.5 G's amazing it's a lot a lot of work  she brings so much of that to the role  it's pretty awesome  you  [Music]  you